obviously the British government is in a
very difficult position in this whole
negotiation because nobody on the
European side asked us to leave what the
British briquette negotiation is doing
is putting the authorities and the other
27 member states and in the European
institutions to a great deal of trouble
and expense on the strength of what was
after all a rather narrow vote in the
referendum 18 months ago so what seems
to have happened recently is there's
been a big reversed 24 hours about the
difference between these two phrases
regulatory alignment and divergence and
for most people if you even look beyond
the gibberish it doesn't seem like
there's all that much difference between
the two do you look at that and think
there is a big difference no I find it
very difficult to see much difference
and you're dancing on the point of a
peon when you get into that sort of
semantic discussion okay there are quite
a lot of particularly sensitive
international negotiations for example
in the case of disputes of walls which
have to be settled in the end on the
basis of very very narrow verbal
definitions but I think really the only
thing that is going to solve the Irish
border issue is concrete proposals about
what is actually going to be done not
about the principle of non divergence or
alignment or convergence or whatever I
suppose the real question is do you
think it's possible for any kind of
agreement to be reached from where we
are now with also a soft border in
Northern Ireland I think it's certainly
possible but it can't be reached without
the British government giving up some
very important so-called red lines which
is laid down and if it wasn't well for
start the
[Music]
they escaped from home if you like to
put it that way from the jurisdiction of
the European Court of Justice because
any agreement that involves matching
regulation or convergence of written
regulation is going inevitably to be
influenced on the European side by the
ultimate arbiter there which is the
European Court so that's one red line
the government has said that there must
be no physical border there must be no
holdups at the border there must be no
visible procedures at the border in
Ireland and we all have great sympathy
with that objective for all the well
known political reasons but it has to be
it has to be put into practice and you
are going to need machinery in order to
understand and ensure that there is no
machinery that is holding things up